I didn't get chance to meet you guys so
yesterday um Jamie do housekeeping here
okay great let's get one thing right I'm
here to help having done my research I
mean the one positive feedback I've had
is about how good the staff are because
I know you know just how bad things are
and having witnessed that service last
night I'm a port is it always like that
yes screaming yes you hear that in the
dining room I've had tables that have
asked if everything was okay in the
kitchen we can't be expected to be
professional all the time when they are
not professional after our chef though
they'll sit down with the table and
expect us to wait on them hand them
drinks until midnight if we leave they
get upset so guests stay here and
they're drinking downstairs in front of
those guests sometimes with the guests
see there's no separation between
business right yeah and personal when
you're sitting here entertaining your
table she'll find something wrong that
you're doing and she'll come and point
it out at you right in front of your
table you know she's just rude she
texted me sometimes really rude text
messages like oh you forgot this or you
forgot that or why didn't you do this
and why wasn't this not just crazy
another problem that we really have been
having is you don't have an actual
payroll system there's no payroll since
then I'll say yeah I'll get you one
and you just never ask him for your
salary yeah I got I got 20 bucks right
now that's all I got right now yeah yeah
tomorrow morning I'll see you then
drip-feeding your salaries my bank does
not take the checks neither does mine
when was the last time you got to start
meeting and discuss this never know I'm
sorry but I want to put an end to all
this is what we're gonna do
they're arriving any minute now my
message to them is if they're not
prepared to bring in a level of
professionalism and understand those
boundaries need to be met on daily basis
they're gonna lose the in and they're
gonna lose you then we're gonna get them
[Music]
I'll chat with the team they're not in a
good place and you've abused them there
are no boundaries of your staff and they
need to be treated a certain way
let's go to Jamie first I'm really
concerned about the abusive text as you
send him why would you send him abusive
you would send me a picture like oh you
forgot this or you didn't do this right
or to me that you worked at a lot of
other places and you knew how to clean
the toilets aren't clean and stuff it's
really important but some of that stuff
doesn't work so it's like I'm sitting
there scrubbing and nothing's coming up
and you'll be like well go do it again
and it's like you trying trying to do
what I can
none of these talent individuals get
paid on time I want to know why they
don't get paid on time because I don't
have a payroll system in place right now
well that's a [ __ ] disgrace that is
disgusting
and then you want them waiting on you up
to all hours of the early morning while
they tidy up after your crap and then
you can't even be bothered to pay them
on time their turn it's a mess no you
are a mess I need to say something
though that almost every single person
here we've given them loans you're
lending the money to buy uniforms to
work in your goddamn business right it's
absurd why why absurd to pay for a
uniform the business should be providing
a uniform
maybe we need to do that yes I never
thought about it that way whose business
is this I've tried to create here a
place where people can come and in and
relax and escape from their stressful
lives escape from their stressful lives
to hear you and Lisa scream at each
other are you [ __ ] kidding me